dans cette période difficile à vivre
tous les parents les enfants
j'ai décidé de faire un petit cadeau un
et petits enfants
mais le veux mes nièces les enfants que
je ne vois plus et c'est qu'à tous les
enfants du monde
le cadeau si quoi je vais le raconter
des histoires des légendes et de contes
de tous les pays
ces histoires et s'écoute les parents
pourront les retrouver sur la page
facebook de l'atelier yuma sous
l'appellation bon dodo t-il de vous vos
besoins tinubu les contenus mais en
douceur avec des petits bruitages des
chansons des petites voix je vous
demande donc de partager abondamment
cette belle chose pour les enfants car
chaque petit compte sept petits grains
de bonheur que vous allez contribuer à
diffuser autour de vous bon dodo doudou
c'est un plaisir ou moins d'offrir cela
aux enfants de tous les pays à très
bientôt
bonjour chez vous